[موسيقى]
مساء الخير مشاهدي العربيه واهلا بكم الى
التاسعه مع ليلى الاختيار استهلها بابرز
ازاله انقاذ الزلزال تحدي كبير يواجه
الاتراك والسوريين والامم المتحده تقر
مجددا لا نستطيع التعامل مع مشرد الزلزال
السلطات التركيه تتوعد المقاولين
المخالفين بالمحاسبه وتحملهم مسؤوليه
ارتفاع حصيله الزلزال
رساله امريكيه الى روسيا خطه ستقلب موازين
الحرب لصالح كياب وتضمن سياده دول البلطيق
[تصفيق]
عم بشرعوا سرقه مصرياتنا ما رح نقبل وفي
لبنان غضبوا المودعين يحرقوا مصارف
والدولار يستولي على تسعيره السلع
باستثناء الخبز
[موسيقى]
نبدا مشاهدينا من الكارثه التي تسبب بها
الزلزال في تركيا وسوريا فمع مرور 11 يوما
ما يزال الكثيرون في عدد المفقودين تحت
الانقاد متوفيين او ربما يتنفسون بانتظار
من ينقذهم رغم تضاؤل تلك الامال فيما تشكل
ازاله انقاذ الزلزال وتنظيف المناطق
تحديات جديده في تركيا توعدت الحكومه
المقاولين ممن خالفوا القوانين في انشاء
الابنيه التي سقطت في الزلزال توعدتهم
بعقاب شديد وحملتهم سبب ارتفاع حصيله
الضحايا اما في سوريا فقد اعلن المرصد ان
حجم الكارثه اكبر بكثير من الامكانيات
المتوفره وان هناك الكثير من المفقودين في
المناطق المنكوبه وان مصير هؤلاء ما زال
مشهولا المرصد اعلن ايضا ان عدد ضحايا
الزلزال من السوريين في تركيا وسوريا وصل
الى حدود 7,500 قتيل مؤكدا ان هناك الكثير
من قتل الزلزال دفنوا بدون تسجيلهم في
ننتقل الان مشاهدينا لمتابعه كلمه لرئيسه
النظام السوري بشار الاسد ولا من نوعه هو
الاكبر بحجمه ولم يعوض نقاط الضعف تلك سوى
الاستجابه العاليه والسريعه من قبل
المؤسسات الحكوميه ومؤسسات المجتمع المدني
والافراد
متطوعين باعمال الانقاذ او متبرعين
بمساعدات علميه او ماليه مقيمين او
مغتربين حاولوا بكل الطرق كسر الحصار
لايصال اي مقدار ممكن
لمساعده اخوتهم المنكوبين
بالاضافه الى المساعدات العاجله التي وصلت
من الدول الشقيقه والصديقه والتي شكلت
دعما هاما لجهود الوطنيه في تخفيف اثار
الزلزال وانقاذ الكثير من المصابين
لكن ومن خلال تجارب الدول الاخرى في هذا
المجال فان لزلزال تداعيات عاجله واجله
وما سنواجه على مدى اشهر وسنوات من تحديات
خدميه واقتصاديه واجتماعيه لا يقل اهميه
عما واجهناه خلال الايام الاولى وهو بحاجه
للكثير من التفكير والحوار والتكافل
والتنظيم لدى مختلف القطاعات الوطنيه
ومن الضروري ان لا ننظر الى تلك التداعيات
كحاله منعزله مرتبطه بالزلزال حصرا بل
كحاله تراكميه للحرب والتخريب الارهابي
وللحصار بتاثيراته والزلزال مؤخرا يضاف
اليها عوامل خلل تراكمه عبر عقود سابقه
للحرب في القطاعات المختلفه
قد يبدو المشهد معقدا وقد يكون من الصعب
الفرز بين الاسباب المؤديه لكل مشكله من
المشكلات على حدا لكنه يعطينا بالمقابل
فرصه لحل تلك المشكلات المتراكمه بشكل
مترابط
وهذا يعني ان ننتقل من معالجه سلبيات ظروف
الطارئه الى اضافه ايجابيات المعالجه
الشامله وما يعنيه ذلك من تطوير وتقدم الى
الامام بدل الاكتفاء بالوقوف في المكان في
مواجهه الازمات
قال منسق الامم المتحده الاقليمي للشؤون
الانسانيه الازمه السوريه مهند هادي أنا
المنظمه تواجه صعوبه في عهد النازحين
لكثره اعدادهم شمال غرب سوريا
نامل ان لا يرتفع عدد الضحايا كثيرا ولكن
مما نراه ونسمعه لا يمنحنا الدمار الذي
خلفه ذلك الزلزال في الحقيقه الكثير من
الامل في ان تكون هذه نهايه الامر قبل ان
يبدا الزلزال كان هناك حوالي اربعه ملايين
ومائه الف شخص بحاجه الى المساعده في شمال
غرب سوريا كثير منهم نازحون الان ومع
تزايد هذا العدد نجد صعوبه كبيره في تحديد
عدد الاشخاص الذين نزحوا مجددا بسبب
الزلزال لكن يمكنني ان اؤكد لكم ان الامم
المتحده وشركائها يبذلون قصار جهدهم
لتوفير الماوى المؤقت لهؤلاء الاشخاص
بالاضافه الى المساعدات الاخرى المطلوبه
[موسيقى]
ماساه الزلزال في سوريا لم تخلو من سجالات
واتهامات بين القوى السياسيه بشان تجاهل
مناطق عديده دمرها الزلزال وقتل وجرح فيها
المئات من سكانها انا فاقد بنتي ولاد
اثنين احبابيان
وبيت حمايه وبكذا ولد كمان يعني مجموعه
حوالي 25 شخص فجاه بتهتز الدنيا
تنزل بنايه مثل طابع البسكوت
في
وبنته وبنته وراحوا
قصص نقلها المرصد السوري لحقوق الانسان عن
الاهالي هناك وقال ناشطون فيها ان ما خلفه
الزلزال من دمار لم يكن في الحسبان
فقد طال الزلزال احدى وعشرين قريه على طول
خط كامل في ريف حلب الجنوبي وصولا الى ريف
حماه الشماليه تلك المناطق تخضع لسيطره
النظام وميليشيات ايرانيه بقيت اياما
تعاني الماساه دون مساعده تذكر
ابرزها سراقب ابو الظهور والحاضر ومعره
النعمان يقول الاهالي ربما كان النظام
وميليشياته يقصدون تجاهلها بعد ان ظلت
عصيه لنحو سبعه اعوام لكن النظام عزا
الامر لضعف الامكانيات
ايضا قرى في عفرين وخاصه بلده جنديرس التي
تكتظ بمهجرين سوريين وتخضع لسيطره فصائل
المعارضه والجيش التركي لم يصلها احد
فتكفل الاهالي بدفن ضحاياهم الى جانب قرى
بريف جبله والقدموس بريف اللاذقيه تعرضت
للتجاهل ما اضطر قاطنيها الى التصرف
بامكانات محدوده
وتقول منظمات انسانيه وحقوقيه ان معظم
القرى التي تم تجاهلها من قبل النظام
والمعارضه تعاني من الفقر وابسط مقومات
الحياه ناهيك عن البنايات التي شيدها
مقاولون وانهارت في اللحظات الاولى من
الزلزال بسبب الغش بمواد البناء
مشاهدينا سانتقل الى هاتاي ومفاجاه
العربيه عمار الهندي عمار ساتحدث عن
الموضوع الذي سنناقشه خلال التاسعه بعد
قليل ولكن للضروره ستكون معنا الان موضوع
اليوم انتشار الاوبئه والامراض فرق
الانقاذ هناك يعني عدد من البروتوكولات
يقومون بها منعا لالتقاط اي عدوى او مرض
ما هي وفينا بهذه التفاصيل لو سمحت
انا اعتقد ليالي انه هذا الموضوع سيكون
مهم جدا من الان وحتى انتهاء هذه العمليات
في عمليات انتشال الضحايا والمفقودين من
تحت الانقاض ولكن سريعا ما شاهدته انا
ومشاهداتي هي اجراءات سلامه خلال انتشال
الجثث بسيطه في الواقع مثلا القفازات
ملابس العزل حينما يخرجوا جثث من تحت
الانقاذ يقوم بحرق ملابس العزل اول باول
للحيلوله دون مثلا انتقالها او وضعها في
مكان ما ولكن لم الاحظ حتى هذه اللحظه
استخدام مثلا مواد تعقيم او رش في
البنايات التي تنتهي فيها عمليات يعني
انتشال الجثث من تحت الانقاض وبالتالي
هنالك يعني
اهم كبير بهذا الجانب ايضا هنالك فرق من
المتطوعين ليال تعمل في انتشال الجثامين
من تحت الانقاض والبحث عن المفقودين هذه
الفرق تعمل من تلقاء نفسها كمتطوعين
وبالتالي ملابس العزل غير متوفره يعني انا
ما شاهدته بان هنالك فرق كثيره ليس لديها
ملابس عزل ليس لديها يعني لديهم قفازات
ولكن الاحتياطات الكبيره ليست
يشكل نعم الا يتم توزيع اي منها يعني
السلطات الرسميه يجب ان تكون على درايه
بهذا الموضوع ام لم يتم تنظيم اي حمله
بخصوص هذا الموضوع حتى الساعه
اعتقد ان المشكله تكمن في التنظيم صحيح
لانه مثلا الكمامات موجوده قفازات موجوده
ولا ولكن ملابس العزل ليست متوفره الا مع
فرق معينه انا شاهدتها ولكن معظم الفرق
المتطوعه التي تعمل في الطرقات وللبحث تحت
الانقاذ لا ترتدي ملابس عزل وبالتالي هذا
تهديد كبير وتحدي كبير والمشكله اعتقد
انها في عمليه التنظيم لانه خلال الايام
القادمه نحن مثلا نستم رائحه الموت ورائحه
الجثث وانا اقف الان اتحدث يعني الرائحه
متواجده في موجوده في كل مكان اينما ذهبت
هنالك رائحه وقويه جدا والسبب بان هذه
الجثث اليوم الحادي عشر تحللت حتى هنالك
صعوبه طبعا في التعرف عليها كما قلنا من
قبل وبالتالي امكانيه انتشار امراض
وانتشار جدا
لدي سؤال اخر لو سمحت بموضوع يعني اليوم
بعض الابنيه تم اخلائها ان كان من الجثث
وان كان من المفقودين وبالتالي نحن نتحدث
عن ركام وحطام فقط الى اين الى اي مكان
يتم نقل هذا الركام ام ان يعني حتى الساعه
ليس هناك مخطه رسميه لعمليه التنظيف اذا
صح التعبير
ما يحدث امرين الامر الاول ان البنايات
الايه للسقوط والمهدده يقوم بهدمها ويترك
الركام في نفس المكان ولكن يضمنوا بان
هدمت البنايات التي على الاغلب ستنهار في
لا قدر الله من جراء هزه ارتداديه ولكن
الركام ازاله الركام لا يتحرك من مكانه هم
الان فقط يقوموا بتامين هذه البنايات التي
من الممكن ان تنهار ولكن ليس هنالك تنظيف
حتى هذه اللحظه لهذا الركام ولا اعلم حقا
كميه الركام الهائل هذه اين ستذهب وهذا
ايضا سؤال مهم انا لم اكن يعني حقيقه فكرت
في هذا الامر ولكن فعلا الركام متواجد في
كل الطرقات حتى البنايات التي انتهت
الاعمال فيها الركام متواجد فيها لا ادري
حتى هذه اللحظه اين سيذهب ولكن هم يقوموا
بهدم البنايات التي ربما تنهار في ايه
لحظه على ايه حال هذه العمليات التي تجري
ربما الاولويه فيها يعني هنالك اولويات رب
ما الاولويه فيها ان تنتهي كل البنايات
وتنظيفها من
من الجثث او ازاله الجثث والجثامين من
تحتها وبعد ذلك ربما تاتي في وقت لاحق هذه
العمليه لكن العنوان الابرز في كل ما يحدث
هنا ان هنالك ربما مشكله في التنظيم حقيقه
وانا لمستها في اكثر من جانب نعم شكرا لك
عمار الهند على هذه الرساله من هاتاي
مرحله جديده دخلتها جهود فرق الانقاذ في
سوريا وهنا نتحدث عن الدفاع المدني او
الخوض البيضاء شمال البلاد اذا انتقلت او
تركزت اعمال تلك الفرق من انتشال الجثث
والبحث عن ناجين الى ازاله ركام الابنيه
المنهاره جراء زلزال من الطرقات سعيا منها
طبعا لفتح تلك الطرق امام مرور شاحنات
الاغاثه والمساعدات للوصول الى مناطق
المتضررين من الزلزال شمال غربي سوريا
تحديدا وتعتمد تلك الجهود على عدد محدود
من الاليات الثقيله ومسانده من اهالي
المنطقه الذين سخروا اليات زراعيه لصالح
تلك العمليه
ايضا عمليه اخرى وهي جدا مهمه اصبحت هي
فتح الطرقات المؤديه الى المضارين من هذا
الزلزال من اجل الوصول المساعدات التي
باتت تدخل بفضل الله من اكثر من معبر
باتجاه شمال غرب سوريا وبدات تصل الى
هؤلاء المتضرين صحيح انها يعني ان اقول لا
زالت خجوله حتى الان وهي غير كافي
للاحتياجات السكان المتدارين من هذا
الزلزال
ينضم الينا مشاهدينا من شمال ادلب الصحافي
مسلم السيد عيسى مسلم يعني ساتطرق للنقطه
التي كنت اتحدث عنها الان وهي عمليه ازاله
الركام او ازاله يعني كل الحطام الذي نتج
عن هذا الزلزال لفتح الطرقات امام
المساعدات وهي النقطه التي كان يتحدث عنها
الدفاع المدني بالامس هل بدات وما المطلوب
فيها وما العوائق فيها
يعني هي هذه المرحله بدات بالفعل لكنها
تحتاج وقت طويل الدفاع المدني هنا يتعامل
مع المرحله بناء على الامكانيات المتوفره
بين يديه وايضا كل الوعود باءت بالفشل
يبدو او تضاءلت بوصول اي مساعدات لمخصصه
للكوارث وغيرها وبالتالي وضع الدفاع
المدني خطه طويله لرفع الانقاض فتح
الطرقات واعاده الابنيه المهدمه وازاله
ركامها يعني في هنا الصوره من خلفي احد
الابنيه المهدمه هنا وسط مدينه ادلب لا
يزال كل شيء على حاله تم انقاذ من كان على
قيد الحياه وبقيت جثث القتلى والذين ابلغ
عنهم ربما تحت هذه الابنيه والانقاذ
وبالتالي نتحدث عن 15 الى 20 يوم حتى
تنتهي كل هذه العمليات ربما وربما تاخذ
وقتا اكثر
لاننا نتحدث عن قرى سكنيه مدمره بالكامل
فوق رؤوس ساكنها هذا ما نتحدث عنه في هذا
السياق لكن كما ذكرت انه تضاءلت الان
الاعمال بوصول اي من المساعدات المخصصه
لرفع الانقاذ وازاله الركام وغيرها
نعم مسلم يعني على الجانب الاخر ايضا يعني
طبعا منذ بدايه الازمه ونحن نتحدث عن
ضروره وصول هناك اليات ثقيله للمساعده
بازاله هذا الركام موضوعا المساعدات
وخصوصا المساعدات الطبيه مساعدات لمراكز
الايواء هل وصل اي شيء جديد اليوم عبر
المعابر التي استحدثت والمعبر الاساسي
الذي هو معبر باب الهوى
ساتحدث في ايجاز عن السياق الانساني لكن
قبل قليل صدر بيان مهم حقيقه لمنسقه
الاستجابه وهو جهه تعمل على الارض
الانسانيه تقوم باحصاء كل الامور المتعلقه
بشان الانسان وهو حقيقه البيان فيه ارقام
مخيفه يعني بدات الارقام لهذه الكارثه
تتكشف تحدث البيان عن 171 الف نازح داخلي
فقط بفعل الزلزال هنا في شمال غرب سوريا
فقط اتحدث انا بالاضافه الى 36 الف شخص
متواجدون فقط في مراكز الايواء بقيه
الارقام توزعت على المخيمات على بيوت
الاقارب وغيرها تحدث ايضا البيان عن 102
112 الف 112 الف
مركز ايواء توزعت في شمال غرب سوريا ايضا
وهذه المراكز تحتوي على اكثر من 35 الف من
الاطفال والنساء فقط وكبار السن هذه
الارقام حقيقه اليوم حتى بدات تتكشف بجهود
الاحصاء وفرق الاحص
لم تبدا ملامحها بالظهور على ارض الواقع
لاننا فقط ما تم تغطيه حتى الان هو خمسه
عشر بالمئه من الاحتياجات الانسانيه بينما
تتوسع دائره الاحتياج بشكل كبير مع وجود
الالاف من السكان والنازحين في مراكز ايضا
البعض نزح من المناطق الجنوبيه في تركيا
ايضا وعاد الى داخل السوري وبالتالي
احتياجات كبيره شكرا لك مسلم السيد عيسى
حدثنا من شمال ادلب
حضاره باكملها غيبها الزلزال في تركيا
فالدمار سيد المشهد لم تختلف في الصوره في
سوريا كلاهما تنعين اجزاء واسعه من مدنهما
هنا يبرز السؤال كيف سيتم التعامل مع
مخلفات الزلازل من تلال الركام واقوام
الحجاره خاصه في المدن المكتظه بالمباني
التي لم تصمد في وجه تلك الهزه الارضيه
فالعمليه تشكل تحديا كبيرا مع وجود عدد
ضخم من الانقاض يشمل الطوب والخرسانه
والاثاثه والممتلكات الشخصيه الخطوه
الاولى تبدا بتنظيف الشوارع والاماكن
العامه من المكدسات عبر الجرافات
والرافعات للسماح للفرق الانقاذ ومنظمه
الاغاثه بالتحرك بحريه وبمجرد ازاله
العوائق عن الطرق يتم التركيز على المباني
نفسها وتقييم الاضرار للتفريق بين الصالح
الصالح منها ثم ياتي دور المهندسين
فيحددون استنادا لاستقرار الهياكل اي
العمارات يمكن اعاده تشييدها وايها يجب
هدمه فاذا كان المبنى غير امن وجب التخلص
منه واذا ما تحدثنا عن الردم سيتعين على
العاملين جمع الانقاض ونقلها الى مكب
النفايات المخصص او مرافق اعاده التدوير
وبانتقاء الخيار الصديق للبيئه ستكون
المهمه مكلفه وصعبه وطويله ولكن بالتاكيد
هي الافضل في تقليل النفايات
وبشكل مجمل وبعض هذا الخراب الذي تخلفه
الزلازل بدقائق وايام معدوده يبقى التحدي
الاكبر هو كيفيه التنسيق بين الوكالات
الحكوميه والمنظمات الانسانيه والخاصه لان
التعافي قد يمتد من شهور الى سنوات
اسراء الصغير العربيه
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا ينضم الينا عبر زوم من جنديرس
خليل شامس وادي زوج عمه الطفله التي ولدت
تحت الانقاض وقريبها للتفكير فقط مشاهدينا
الطفله التي وصفت بالطفله المعجزه والتي
ولدت تحت الانقاض والتي يعني عمت وكل
العالم تحدث عنها خليل يعني اليوم السؤال
الاساسي كيف هي الطفله هل هي بصحه جيده
واين هي الان
وضعها الصحي مستقر وهي بحاله جيده وهي
الان في مستشفى جيهان التخصصي
يعني كنتم بالساعات الماضيه تحدثتم عن
ان تم نقله الى مكان امن لماذا مكان امن
لا هي للشعر حتى الان بالمشفى
الجيهان التخصصي وهي بحاله جيده وهي كلها
اشاعات يعني
واخبار ما في منها الحكي هذا خالص ليش ما
تم اخدا للمنزل حتى الساعه
الاطمئنان على صحتها اكثر ونحن الان نقوم
باجراءات قضائيه وقمنا بالتحليل
من اجل
صله القرابه طبعا هذه هذه التحاليل هذه
التحاليل طلبت من جهات مختصه ومسؤوله في
المنطقه وبالتالي انتم اليوم يعني
تقومون بالتدابير والاجراءات لتسجيل رسميا
على اسمك
تبنيها نعم
على اسمك استاذ خليل يعني هل هناك هناك
بعض الاخبار التي تتحدث عن خلاف بالعائله
على تبني هذه الفتاه هل هناك اي احد من
العائله يحق له تبني الفتاه
لا لا ما في بالعكس انا
عندي وراح تكون وحده من اولادي يعني ما في
فرق ان شاء الله وراح تكون اغلى من ولادي
كمان طيب يعني كل القصص كل القصص التي
سمعناها بالساعات الماضيه عن محاوله خطفها
عن محاوله الاتجار فيها كل هذا ما هي
فيلا اشاعات وانا اشكر الجهات المختصه
الشرطه والكذا الاقامه بحمايه اكثر
والجيش الوطني كامل يعني بحمايتها
بحمايتها بحمايتها من ماذا هي طفله اعربت
منذ الساعات الاولى بانك يعني تريد تبنيها
وهي بالمستشفى يتم علاجه حمايتها من ماذا
من شفتي
الاخبار النظام السوري حاول
وانه هي بمناطقم وكذا
النظام يحاول خطفه ام انه اشخاص يحاولون
خطف لبيع
النظام هو اللي حاول بده يخطفها
بالمصاري طبعا
شكرا لك استاذ خليل شامي السوادي زوج عمه
الطفله التي ولدت تحت الانقاض ان نتمنى
يعني ان تتم رعايتها رعايه جيده جدا لانها
فعلا طفله
مشاهدينا التاسعه مستمره وفيها بعد قليل
الملابس التي يرتدونها حينما يقوم باخراج
جثامين او جثث يحرقونها بشكل سليم مباشر
الى جانب المبلغ مبنى ويرتدون غيرها ما
لازلت لا اعرف حقيقه ما اذا كانت العمليات
لمشاهد تعيد للذاكره بدايات مواجهه كورونا
فرق الانقاذ التركيه ترتدي ستر واقيه
لتفادي اوبئه ما بعد السلسله
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد قلى وزير الدفاع
الامريكي لدى الصين النواشه لديها خطه
ستقلب موازين الحرب في اوكرانيا لصالح
كياف مضيفا انا القوات الروسيه سيئه
التجهيز والتدريب ولذلك هم يتكبدون الكثير
من الضحايا
روسيا تواصل ادخال اعداد كبيره من القوات
الى ساحه القتال هذه القوات سيئه التجهيز
وسيئه التدريب وبسبب ذلك فانهم يتكبدون
الكثير من الخسائر ونتوقع ان يستمر ذلك
ولدينا خطه ستقلب موازين الحرب لصالح
اوكرانيا
الشيء الاخير الذي ساشير اليه فقط هو انه
قبل الغزو الروسي التقيت بوزير الدفاع
استونيا وقلت له انه اذا غزت روسيا
اوكرانيا فسننشر قواتنا في استونيا في
اليوم التالي وقد فعلنا ذلك كنا اول من
وصل والتزمنا بكل كلمه قلناها وسنفي
بالتزاماتنا في المستقبل
مع اقتراب الذكرى السنويه الاولى للحرب في
اوكرانيا فقدت موسكو الاف الدبابات وعشرات
الالاف من رجالها من اجل اخضاع اوكرانيا
تقول الارقام الغربيه ورغم ذلك بقي الرئيس
الروسي فلاديمير بوتين مترددا باستخدام
الطائرات والمروحيات للفوز بمعركه الجو
بحسب صحيفه التايمز البريطانيه في بدايه
الحرب مشاهدينا كانت الصواريخ الباليستيه
هي الطريقه الوحيده الرئيسيه التي
استخدمها بوتين في معركه الجو مع الاحتفاظ
بطائراته وطائراته الباهظه الثمن في
الاحتياط مثل مثلا المقاتله الروسيه اسيو
35 التي تبلغ تكلفتها حوالي 42 مليون
دولار تكتيكو بوتين الجوي نجح الى حد ما
تقول الصحيفه بعدما دعم صواريخ الروسيه
بالطائرات المسيره الايرانيه الرخيصه
الثمن وضرب بها البنى التحتيه الحيويه في
اوكرانيا رغم اسقاط اكياف ل 50% من هذه
الطائرات المسيره هناك مخاوف كبيره من ان
تلجا موسكو فجاه الى اغراق الدفاع الجوي
الاوكراني بالقاذفات والطائرات المقاتله
والمروحيات الجويه وكذلك الصواريخ هي
محاوله لايماله الحرب لصالح موسكو هنا
بحسب التايمز البريطانيه نستعرض معا
مشاهدينا القوه الجويه التي تمتلكها كل من
روسيا واوكرانيا بهذا العرض هنا لدى روسيا
41282 طائره في حين تمتلك اوكرانيا
312 طائره موسكو تمتلك
773 طائره مقاتله وكيف 99 كما تمتلك روسيا
537 مروحيه هجوميه واوكرانيا تمتلك ثلاث
33 كما نشاهد هنا
[موسيقى]
قال الرئيس البيلاروسيا الاكزر لوكاشينكو
ان العدوان على بلادنا ليس فقط من قبل
اوكرانيا وان اي محاولات للاعتداء سيتم
الرد عليها بكل قسوه
حول عدوان محتمل ضد بيلاروسيا الامر لا
يتعلق فقط باوكرانيا بل ينطبق ايضا على
جيراننا من بلدان مختلفه فاذا ارتكبوا اي
اعتداءات ضد بيلاروسيا سنرد عليهم بكل
قسوه وستاخذ الحرب طابعا مختلفا تماما هذه
المره
ينضم الينا مشاهدينا من دونياس الاغبر
مراسل العربيه وايضا
العربيه سابدا معك عبد الجواد وسطه يعني
هذا التصعيد الدبلوماسي السياسي العسكري
من جهه بيلاروسيا وروسيا على اوكرانيا كيف
هي الصوره من هناك وماذا رصدت على الارض
مساء الخير ليال لك وللزميل رائد نعم
بالفعل يعني بيلاروسيا حتى هذه اللحظه
تتحدث عن انها لن تقوم بتشكيل اي هجوم
عسكري من قبلها لا على اوكرانيا ولا على
اي دول مجاوره في حال لم تتعرض اراضيها
لاي تهديد خطر لكن طبعا الرئيس البيلاروسي
الكسندر اليوم في حديثه وردا على العربيه
تحدث بان موس يعني بان مينز لن تقف مكتوفه
الايدي وستقدم لموسكو خيار استخدام
الاراضي البيلاروسيه على الارض والجو في
حال طلبه موسكو هذا الشيء طبعا اليوم راح
يتحدث طويلا عن العمليه العسكريه الروسيه
في الاراضي الاوكرانيه وانه من الضروري
الوصول لطاوله المفاوضات مهما كان الوضع
صعب في هذه في هذا الوقت لكن طبعا على
الارض ليال ما زال الوضع متوتر بشكل كبير
لا يمكنني الحديث على ان القلق لا يسود
الشارع البيلاروسيا الجميع يتحدث عن ان
المرحله القادمه هي مرحله تصعيد كريمه
كبيره قد تشترك بيلاروسيا في العمليه
العسكريه وقد يحدث يعني ما يحمد عقباه كما
يقال لذلك طبعا الوضع في بيلاروسيا الان
هو وضع شبه عسكري الخط الحدودي الفاصل بين
بيلاروسيا واوكرانيا هو متوتر بشكل كبير
تواجد للقوات الاوكرانيه تدعم حرس الحدود
والمعدات الثقيله طبعا رغم عدم وجودها في
شوارع المدينه لكن الكثير يتحدث عن
تواجدها واستعدادها للرد في حال تعرض
سياسي دبلوماسي اسمح لي عبد الجواد ان
انتقل الى الزميل رائد الاغبر لنقل الصوره
صوره المعارك على الارض رائد اليوم هناك
تصريحات امريكيه هناك كانت دروسي كيف هي
صوره المعارك على الارض ولماذا هذا هذا
الاستنفار
مساء الخير لك ليال وللزميل عبد الجواد
بالفعل هنا الاوضاع العسكريه بتطور دائم
ومضطرد حيث ان الارتال العسكريه التي
تتنقل ما بين المحاور ان كانت الجنوبيه او
الشماليه من مقاطعه دانياس هناك ضغط كبير
من قبل القوات الروسيه على مدن كثيره مثل
باقي
في جنوب اوغلادار بالفعل تسيطر قوات في
المنطقه الشماليه على بلده والبلده في هذه
الايام تطوق قوات باجنر بلده
براسك هذه البلده يعني محاصر فيها 1500
جندي الحديث ان هذا الحصار يمكن ان يطول
لان
الجنود المحصنون لديهم كميه كبيره من
الاسلحه ويمكنهم ان يدافعوا عن انفسهم
كثيرا لكن هناك تواجد وحضور لسلاح الجو
الروسي في المنطقه بشكل دائم يحلق تحلق
المقاتلات الروسيه في سماء دانيس بشكل
يومي كما ان المدافع الحديثه والطائرات
الحديثه وكذلك الحديثه وصلت الى ارض
المعركه قبل وصول الدبابات الامريكيه
والالمانيه هناك معركه كبيره قادمه اظن في
شهر مارس او في الاشهر القادمه ستشهد
المنطقه استعارا حقيقيا بالمعارك حيث ان
القوات الروسيه تحضر لهذه المواجهه وكذلك
الجانب الاوكراني يرفض الانسحاب من باقمه
رغم كل الضغط والحصار الذي يعني التطويق
الذي ينفذه الجيش الروسي على القوات
الاوكرانيه ورغم نصائح الغرب في الجيش
الاوكراني بالانسحاب من المدينه الى ان
اوكرانيا حتى الان صامده وترفض الانسحاب
من المدينه وتقول بانها قادره على الصمود
والمقاومه شكرا لكما مراسله الى العربيه
عبد الجواد الرشد من منسك ورائد الاخبار
من دوني ايسك
[موسيقى]
بالعوده مشاهدينا لملفات الزلازل وتحديدا
الزلزال الذي ضرب تركيا وسوريا حذر الصليب
الاحمر بان سوريا قد تواجه تفشي الامراض
بشكل خطير في اعقاب الزلزال المدمر الذي
وقع الاسبوع الماضي اذا لم يحصل مئات
الالف من النازحين على مساكن دائمه في
القريب العاجل
الناس كانوا بالفعل غارقين في الازمه
وبالطبع الزلزال يجعل الامر اكثر صعوبه
الوضع الصحي تحت الضغط ايضا نقص الوقود
والتضخم والازمه الاقتصاديه وتاثر النظام
الصحي بشده جراء وباء كوفيد 19 كلها اشياء
تجعل الامر اكثر صعوبه
11 يوما على كارثه الزلزال والامال بالعضو
بالعثور على احياء تحت الانقاض بدات
تتضائل لا بل انتهت ربما والفرق الانقاذ
في سوريا وتركيا انتقلت الى مرحله انتشال
الجثثمين من تحت الانقاب فرق الانقاذ
ارتدت ملابس العزل والحمايه لانتشال
الجثامين خشيه من انتشار الامراض والاوبئه
بسبب وجود الضحايا تحت الانقاد كما هو
معلوم وكما نشاهد فيها تاي التركيه لكن
الجثث المتبقيه تحت الالقاد ما مصيرها وهل
تحللها سيؤدي الى امراض وتلوث للبيئه
مشاهدينا درجات الحراره المنخفضه الى
مادون الصفر في تركيا ساهمت حتى الساعه
بشكل كبير الى عدم تحلل الجثث بسرعه
وبالتالي انتشار الامراض لن يشكل خطرا
كبيرا الا في حال بقيت لوقت طويل من دون
انتش من تحت الانقاد وافقه طبعا خبراء
للصحه وفيما يتعلق بالرائحه الكريهه
المنبعثه من الجثث تحت الالقاد اكد خبراء
الصحه ان الرائحه التي انتشرت في المناطق
المنكوبه مصدرها الرئيسي شبكه الصرف الصحي
التي تضررت بشكل كامل بعد الزلزال وهذا
الامر سيؤدي حتما الى انتشار الاوبئه في
حال لم يتم معالجته من قبل السلطات بوقت
القريب
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا للحديث عن تداعيات هذا الموضوع
ينضم الينا عبر زوم من الدكتور احمد سلمان
استاذ علم المناعه وتطوير اللقاحات استاذ
احمد سابدا من موضوع اساسي وهو موضوع
التزاحم الذي ايضا يولد امراض كثيره بسبب
وجود الناس بالعراء ببقع جغرافيه محدوده
جدا اتحدث هنا عن شمالي سوريا وايضا عن
المناطق التركيه ما هي الامراض التي يمكن
ان تتكاثر بسبب عامل الازدحام
تحياتي استاذه ليال وطبعا خالص عزائنا
لاخواننا في تركيا وسوريا ويعني ضحايا
زلزال نسال الله ان يتقبلهم من الشهداء
يعني
واعزائنا طبعا هو للاسف يعني المنطقه اللي
حدث فيها زلزال بالفعل كان فيها تكدس
نتيجه انه كان فيها عدد كبير من اللاجئين
وكانت يعني مناخ مناسب لانتشار الاوبئه
وطبعا في وجود فصل الشتاء بيكون يعني مناخ
مناسب جدا لانتشار الاوبئه التنفسيه خصوصا
يعني للاسف في الاطفال وبالتالي
الفتره الحاليه نتيجه طبعا يعني كما ذكر
التقرير التلوث اللي هيكون موجود مثلا
نتيجه
الخلل والتسرب اللي بيحدث من
شبكه الصرف الصحي انخفاض درجه الحراره
تكدس يعني النجيم نسال الله ان يحفظهم في
يعني اماكن ضيقه وبالتالي مع عدم وجود
التغذيه السليمه والتقويه السليمه والغذاء
السليم والادويه كل ده للاسف سيكون له
تاثير مباشر على ازدياد فرصه الاصابات
بالامراض على راس هذه الامراض للاسف
التنفسيه لانه احنا في فصل الشتاء شيء
طبيعي ان هو تكدس عدد كبير من الناس وعدم
التدفئه السليمه في مكان ضيق سيساهم في
انتشار الاصابات بصوره اسرع وبالتالي طبعا
توفر الادويه واللقاحات اذا امكن ضد
الامراض التنفسيه عموما سواء في الوانزا
او كورونا سيكون لها دور كبير جدا في الحد
من هذه الاصابات النظافه الشخصيه مهمه جدا
على حسب طبعا الامكانيات المتاحه
لامياه لا تغيير ملابس ولا شيء هم بالعراء
يعني الزملاء رصدوا بعض موجود منذ اسبوع
بدون ولا نقطه مياه يعني على جسده
وبالتالي الخطر اعلى بكثير للاسف للاسف
يعني لذلك يعني المؤسسات الدوليه يعني
نظام الصحه العالميه والحكومات طبعا لابد
ان تاخذ يعني هذا الموضوع يعني بسرعه
التحرك
للحد من الاضرار اللي للاسف ستمتد لفتره
طويله ليست فقط من اثار الزلزال ولكن من
الاثار التي تترتب اثار الانسانيه المؤلمه
تحدثنا عن المياه وعن شبكات الصرف الصحي
بالامس وقبل امس ولكن هناك نقطه اخرى بسبب
تضرر هذه الشبكات الحشرات كيف يمكن ان
تتكاثر اكثر وتساهم بنقل الامراض اكثر
اكيد يعني الحشرات لها دور كبير في اللي
هي
او البكتيريا عموما هتكون طبعا لها مناخ
جيد لكن يعني هنفترض انه وجود درجه حراره
منخفضه ده قد يكون عامل جيد في الحد من
سرعه تكاثر البكتيريا والحشرات عموما
وبالتالي نعمل ان هو هيكون ان شاء الله
الوضع افضل من هذه الناحيه خلال فتره
الشتاء وان كان طبعا للاسف له تاثير يعني
هو سلاح ذو حدين يمكن القول ان هو الشتاء
سيكون له اضرار في سرعه انتشار امراض
معينه ولكن ايضا سيحد من انتشار يعني
الحشرات او الامراض اللي بتتطلب عوائل
بكتيريه في انتشارها او تكاثرها بسرعه
بخلاف ما يحدث في فصل الصيف مهم ايضا انه
يعني طبعا هو كل الامكانيات صعب جدا انها
تتوفر ولكن
التغذيه السليمه اذا امكن يعني حتى يتم
تقويه المناعه للتعامل مع الوضع ده قدر
المستطاع يعني هي كلها للاسف ظروف صعبه
جدا ولكن على حسب ما هو متاح يعني سيتم
تقليل الضرر قبل يعني قصد المستطاع
ولابد طبعا من تدخل الجهات المعنيه ويعني
التبرع نتحدث عن يعني حاله صحيه اذا صح
التعبير يدق لها ناقوس الخطر شكرا لك عبرز
من الدكتور احمد سلمان استاذ علم المناعه
وتطوير اللقاحات
مشاهدينا تتابعنا في التاسعه ولكن بعد
قليل
العربيه ترافق الجيش العراقي في جوله
حصريه على الحدود مع ايران وتركيا
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد اعلنا وزير الاقتصاد
اللبناني امين سلام ان حكومه تصريف
الاعمال قررت السماح بتسعير السلع
بالدولار واعتماد سعر صرف العمله الاجنبيه
الرائج في السوق نظرا لعدم امكانيه
التعويل على سعر منصه معينه واضاف الوزير
انه لن يتم تسعير الخبز بالدولار وان
الحكومه اتاحت مهله حتى الاربعاء المقبل
لتطبيق الاليه الجديده لضبط الاسعار
هذا هو اقدم محتاجون على احراق واجهه احد
المصارف اللبنانيه في منطقه بادارو في
العاصمه اللبنانيه بيروت وقطع المحتاجون
السير في المنطقه واشعل الاطارات المطاطيه
امام فروع المصارف وذلك بسبب الارتفاع
الجنوني في سعر صرف الدولار والتهرب
المصارف من دفع الودائع للمواطنين كما
شهدت مدينه صيدا وبلده بنايه للبقاعيه
قطعا للطرق للاسباب نفسها
[موسيقى]
ابراهيم ابراهيم
كيف عم بشرعوا سرقه مصرياتنا ما رح نقبل
هذا تحرك بسيط قدام اللي بده يصير نحنا
بطل فارقه معنا نحنا مصرياتنا بتعادل
ارواحنا الغلا اللي
عم بيصيح حطونا بمطرح نقدر نكون عنا رؤيه
نحن واياكم بالنهار ما في شي بتسكر
البنوته تاني نهار عم يشتغلوا في باموالنا
من اموالنا ونحن اموالنا ما فينا نتصرف
فيها ما فينا نشتري ربطه خبز باموالنا
هالي حراميه مجرمين
مشاهدينا ينضم الينا من بيروت الدكتور
جهاد الحكيم استاذ التمويل الدولي في
الجامعه الامريكيه في بيروت دكتور جهاد
يعني بعيدا عن النظريات السياسيه وعن
التنظير السياسي ما يحصل اليوم من انفلات
لسعر صرف الدولار ببيروت وانفلات مالي
واقتصادي هو متوقع بالارقام منذ بدايه هذه
الازمه ومعرفه الطبقه الحاكمه يعني القيام
بالاصلاحات الماليه المطلوبه القيام بخطه
اقتصاديه وماليه مطلوبه ما الافق امام هذه
الازمه وانفلات الشارع اليوم
سيدتي لقد خسرت الليره اللبنانيه اكثر من
82% من قيمتها في نهايه سنه 2020
واكثر من
94% من قيمتها بنهايه عام
2021 وبالتالي خسرت الليره اغلبيه قيمتها
بنهايه 2020 وبالتالي اليوم لم يعد مهما
الارقام التي نصل اليها ولقد قلنا منذ
مطلع 2020 انه اقل مخاسرناه هو الليره
اللبنانيه لانه يمكن ان نعوض هذا الامر
عندما نحسن من الاقتصاد اللبناني لانه سعر
صرف الليره يجب ان يكون مراه للاقتصاد
انما الشعب اللبناني يخسر مكانته
والبرندينج وسيطه والقدره التفاوضيه
وكرامته هذا هو المهم عندما نغير هذه
الطبقه الممسكه
بالسياسات النقديه والماليه والاقتصاديه
يمكن ان نستعيد دور الليره ونستعيد الدور
الذي نحن نريده لكن اليوم بوجودهم لا يمكن
هناك محاوله هروب الى الامام عبر جعل
المؤامرات الدوليه هي السبب بكل الانهيار
الحاصل في الداخل ولكن يعني اليوم مع
سياسه الترقيع التي انتهجها المركزي
بالسنوات الماضيه والاشهر الماضيه
واستخدام كل الاحتياطي المتبقي من اموال
اللبنانيين الموجود بالمركزي خدمه للطابقه
سياسيه لم تعد تنفع ما الخيارات المطروحه
اذا لم يتم هناك يعني ايجاد حل سياسي
واقتصادي بان واحد
هنالك سقوط حر سيدتي على كافه المستويات
نحن لن اضحي
بالشبان والشابات نحن نضحي بهم لانه اصبحت
العائلات اللبنانيه
منتشره بانحاء العالم ونحن نقوم بتنويع
العائلات اللبنانيه من اجل الصمود بلبنان
كما يجب ان ينوع كما يجب ان تنوع المحفظه
الماليه وهذا للاسف كل من ليس لديه احد في
الخارج هو يرسله اليوم الى الخارج لكي
يرسل له بعض الدولارات كي يتمكن من الصمود
لفتره اكبر لكن ليس هنالك من اي تغطيه
صحيه
والمواطن اللبناني متروك لمصيره المجهول
هنالك عمليه تنكيل بالشعب اللبناني
مستويات الفقر المتقع والفقر غير محموله
لقد حذر من ذلك كل المؤسسات الدوليه
الاسكوا و غيرها ونحن مخطوفين في لبنان
نحن خصوصا امام دوله اسيوط بشكل نهر
المواطن بظل يعني القدره الشرائيه
المتدنيه وكل الاوضاع الصعبه ستفاقم كل
هذه الارقام التي تتحدث عنها شكرا لك جهات
حكيم استاذ التمويل الدولي في الجامعه
الامريكيه في بيروت على هذه المداخله
[موسيقى]
طبيعه الحدود العراقيه طالما شكلت تحديا
امنيا بسبب صعوبه التضاريس وانتشار
الجماعات المسلحه فيها ذرائع يحاول العراق
سدها والانتشار على حدوده ضمن مرحله اولى
رافقته العربيه فيها ورفضت المواقع
المتقدمه التي اقامتها قوات الحدود على
النقاط الصفريه مع ايران وتركيا فلنتابع
[موسيقى]
ها
بدت يسيره عند شرحها لنا على الخرائط جوله
حصريه يرافق فيها قوه حرس الحدود العراقيه
لرصد الاوضاع الامنيه المتوتره على الحدود
مع ايران وتركيا
لكنهم ابلغونا ان المهمه على الارض ستكون
اصعب بكثير لم يمضي وقت طويل حتى تبين ذلك
ثلوج وتضاريس وعره ابطات حركه تنا ثم
اوقفتها قبل ان نكمل سيرنا عناصر الحرس
يقولون ان هذا اقل ما يواجهونه لتنفيذ خطه
مراقبه الحدود التي وضعتها بغداد شهر
اكتوبر الماضي
[موسيقى]
هنا العراق وهذه ايرانه وصلنا الى اخر
نقطه حدوديه بين البلدين جبل كودو هذا
الجبل الذي كان مهما في القتال بين
الجانبين اثناء الحرب بين البلدين ثم بعد
الحرب بقي حقل الغامن وضع امني استغلته
جماعه مسلحه للتسلل والتمركز والانتشار
لكن هذا الوضع انتهى منذ سته اشهر فقط
حينما وصلت قوات الحدود لاول مره منذ
1991 الى هذا الجبل اسعى العراق لتثبيت
سياده على ارضه ولسد ذرائع جارته افتتحجج
طهران بعمليه التسلل وبانتشار جماعات
معارضه للنظام الايراني لتشن ضربات على
مواقع داخل العراق
بعد وصولنا هنا بعد سته اشهر حتى الان لم
يحصل اي حاله تسلل او تهريب في هذه
المنطقه لاننا الان نحن على خط الصفر بين
الحدود العراقيه الايرانيه وهذه كما ترون
نقطه ايرانيه مقابل مخافر الحدوديه
العراقيه يهدف العراق الى نشر قواتها على
كل الحدود مع ايران حتى في المساحات التي
كانت خاليه لعقوده بس عن يقول انه يحتاج
لتحقيقه الى طائره مسيره تراقب الحركه في
المنطقه كما يحتاج لعدد اكبر من عناصر قوه
الحدود ولتزويدهم باسلحه متطوره
[موسيقى]
من الحدود العراقيه الايرانيه الى حدود
العراق وتركيا وصلنا نرافق قوات حرس
الحدود العراقيه في هذه الرحله الخاصه لنا
لنواكب تنفيذ المرحله الاولى من خطه نشر
القوات العراقيه مرحله مخصصه للمثلث
الحدودي العراقي التركي الايرانيه
على حدود تركيا رزمه عنوانها واحد حزب
العمال كردستاني الذي ينتشر منذ عقود في
مواقع مختلفه في العراق منها اقليم
كردستان كانت اكو تواجد لمسلحي حزب العمال
الكردستاني في بعض مناطقنا ولكن بعد تقدم
قوات الحدود العراقيه وفي معاونه لهذه
المناطق لم يبقى اي مسلح
في هذه المناطق وتم بناء قلاع
لقواتنا الحرس الحدود القوات البيشمرقه
موجودنا وموجوده خلفنا هي تدعم قوات حرس
حدود في هذه المنطقه اكو برنامج الحكومه
المركزيه والحكومه اقليم كردستان
نتوزع على الشريط الحدود على خط الصفر
نفتح مخافر وتواجد بها القوات الحدود لكن
القرار العراقي بالانتشار لا يكفي فهناك
تفاهمات سياسيه لابد من التوصل اليها بين
بغداد وانقره مع تحديات امنيه بشان قبول
حزب العمال الكردستاني بالواقع الجديد
الصعاب قوه البيشمر في اقليم كردستان
لموقعها الثاني على الحدود
سار بن عيشوبه العربيه كردستان العراق
[موسيقى]
قطار سام يغضب سكان ولايه اوهايو
الامريكيه بعد اسبوعين على حادثه القطار
الذي خرج عن مساره وادى الى انفجار ضخم
نتج عنه سحابه غاز ضخمه حملت مواد
كيميائيه وسامه ومصرطنه وفقا للسلطات
المحليه هناك سكان المنطقه طالبوا السلطات
بضمانات بشان صحتهم المهدده مع استمرار
انبعاث الروائح السامه بعد اسبوعين من
الحادث الانفجار كان وقع في بلده تدعى شرق
فلسطين يسكنها حوالي خمسه الاف شخص وعندما
خرج القطار عن مساره كان يحمل ماده كلوريد
فاينل التي تسببت وتسبب مرض السرطان شركه
سكك الحديد المشغله اوضحت ان 20 عربه من
بين اكثر من 100 عربه في القطار كانت تحمل
مواد خطره والقطار كذب متجها من ماده
فينيا سبب انحراف القطار عن مساره وفق
التحقيقات الاوليه تقول انه ربما بسبب
مشكله ميكانيكيه في محور عربه السكك
الحديديه وراي اخر اعتبر ان ربما كانت
الحموله الزائده هي السبب ماده الكلوريد
الفاينل الكلوريد التي انفجرت وتحولت الى
غازات سامه تستخدم بصناعه البلاستيك الصلب
كما هو معروف لاجل ذلك تحركت وكاله حمايه
البيئه لمراقبه جوده الهواء كل يوم حتى
الاطمئنان من نقاء الهواء من اي مواد سامه
المنطاد الصيني لا يزال يشغل الولايات
المتحده والاستخبارات في البلاد تتحقق في
هويه العالم الذي او العالم الذي طور هذا
المنطاد والرجل المثير للجدل هو الباحث
الصيني المرموق في جامعه بيهنج
الذي يرجح ان يكون واحدا من المعقول
التقنيه والابتكار في البلد الاسيوي
وللمصادفه فقد فرضت واشنطن عقوبات على
شركات صينيه في العاشر من فبراير رجالي اي
في اليوم الذي يصادف عيد الميلاد السادس
والستين لهذا العالم الصيني ولم تشهر
السلطات الامريكيه بالاسم الى العالم
الصيني ولكنها اوضحت انها فرضت العقوبات
على الشركات بسبب دورها في امداد الجيش
الصيني بمعدات واليات للتجسس والاستطلاع
من جانب اخر المنطاد الصيني فتح شهيه
الامريكيين على السخريه من اخبار الاجسام
الغريبه والمجهوله التي ظهرت في بحيره
ميشيغان الامريكيه واخلاق المجال فيها
لاسباب تتصل بالدفاع القومي ابرز
التعليقات جاءت من الملياردير الامريكي
الى ماسك حيث علق ساخرا بالقول لا تقلقوا
بعض من اصدقاء الفضائيين سيزورون الارض
[موسيقى]
ختام التاسعه مشاهدينا مع العناوين
ازاله انقاذ الزلزال تحدي كبير يواجه
الاتراك والسوريين والامم المتحده تقرر
مجددا لا نستطيع التعامل مع مشاهدي
الزلزال
السلطات التركيه تتواعد المقاولين
المخالفين بالمحاسبه وتحملهم مسؤوليه
ارتفاع حصيله الزلزال
رسالاتنا امريكيه الى روسيا خطه ستقلب
موازين الحرب لصالح كياب وتضمن سياده دول
البلطيق وفي لبنان غضب المودعين يحرق
مصارف والدولار يستولي على تسعيره السلع
باستثناء الخبز